hey here we go a couple of things sorry
I forgot to bring candy but it'll be on
sale next week so we can probably bring
it next week but I walking over I
thought boy those of you who are here
deserves some candy but I've just tried
to sprinkle in a few interesting slides
for your benefit I saw this on the MIT
news of the day and I thought that was
really cool who would have thought to
turn the giant dome into a Halloween
pumpkins and I was also jealous this
morning when my husband got ready to go
work in the emergency room and he put on
his Star Trek outfit so I didn't even
have it because I don't usually get to
actually have a class on the day of
Halloween or so he headed off I think
people are unfortunately gonna expect
him to be able to really fix things very
readily in the emergency room today
because he's gonna have all those extra
powers that he doesn't usually have but
anyway anyway so actually it's kind of a
good day for a lecture Halloween because
we're going to talk about the
fight-or-flight response which is a
great paradigm for cellular signaling so
you're gonna see how signaling really
works in action because what one has to
think about with respect to cellular
signaling is that it's dynamic and
transient and when we look at the
molecular details of the switches that
enable dynamics and transient behavior
in cells you're going to see how
perfectly adapted they are for these
types of responses that have to be
carried out in cells are in organs in
order to respond to a particular signal
rapidly and with a definitive time frame
and then have that signal then stopped
once the the time frame is passed so I
really want to sort of stress to you the
characteristics of signaling that that
can emerge just by knowing about two
particular cell by cellular switches
knowing the molecular details of those
switches to
understand then when we look at them in
action in a couple of cellular signaling
pathways then we'll see how adapted
those signals are and the great thing
about biology is the once you learn a
few very specific things then those
often get reused in nature so the
cellular signals that I'm going to
describe to you are used again and again
in different formats to create different
signaling pathways so it's not at every
pathway in every cell in the body has
different nuances it has general
paradigms that we can learn about and
understand all right so the key feature
is then to think about the the the the
molecular basis of these switches so
last time I was talking to you about
cellular signaling and remember there's
always a signal a response and an output
so something happens it's a signal it's
usually a molecule of some kind outside
the cell or able to diffuse into the
cell as a function of that signal
there's a response so this is molecular
the response obviously is biochemical
and the output is biological so I want
you to sort of think about these as we
look at pathways what's really my output
at the end of a particular signaling
pathway what was my input how did it get
to the cell how does it have a dramatic
effect on the cell as a whole how does
the timing and action of this effect
occur so rapidly
so we talked last time about different
types of signals those that mostly occur
in this in the cytoplasm of the cell
with signals that are able to diffuse
across the plasma membrane and bind to
an intracellular receptor and then cause
an action but really the most important
ones for today
going to be the types of receptors that
span the membrane and the reason why
these are much more significant they're
more in number they're more predominant
is if you have a membrane spanning
receptor you have the opportunity to use
signals of very very different types
small polar molecules small proteins
lipids amino acids carbohydrates you've
got a much larger range of signals than
you could possibly have
if you restricted yourselves to the type
of signals that can cross the cell
membrane those are very limited to
nonpolar small molecules that can get
across the membrane the more dominant
types of signals are going to be the
ones that are outside the cell they
arrive at a cell surface they bind to
attract a receptor that is trans
membrane and transduce a signal from the
outside to the inside so that's that's
an important term here the process of
transducing external information -
internal information so when we started
the course we were really thinking about
laying down the cellular membrane as an
encased environment where things could
occur at high concentrations you could
set up systems that were functional
within membranes but in doing that
within a membrane encased area in doing
that you've built a formidable barrier
around the cell so the types of
receptors that we'll talk about are
those that have adapted to take this
external information into the cell and
then have a cellular consequence occur
so I'm going to talk to you about two
specific types of cellular switches and
they're going to be intracellular
and we're going to be referring back to
these because they're going to be
important as we dissect a signaling
pathway so the first type so stand aside
a moment put aside a moment the actual
process of a signal binding the response
both biologic biochemical and biological
let's look first at the molecular detail
of these switches and see how they are
adapted to their function and the first
type of cellular switch i want to known
as g proteins the G is because they bind
guanidine nucleotides so that's why
they're called G proteins they're small
proteins that bind G DP or g GP so this
is the guanine nucleotide that has
either two phosphates guanosine
diphosphate or triphosphate so there may
or may not be a third phosphate here and
the g proteins bind them and the
dynamics of the situation are that when
g proteins are bound to gdp they are
inactive the switch is off there's an
aspect of the structure and it's very
dependent on how many phosphates there
are in this structure but it's when it's
bound to the diphosphate variant of the
nucleotide then it's an off switch and
when it's bound to gtp it's an on switch
and it's active so this is a the
molecular basis of one of the switches
they relies on the
the conformational dynamics of these
small G proteins and when that shape is
quite different if it's bound to
guanosine diphosphate or triphosphate
and we'll take a look in a moment and
how the structure the shape changes the
shape shifts upon binding the
triphosphate analog so this is a dynamic
inter conversion when the GTP is
hydrolyzed you go back to the gdp bound
state the off state and there are a
variety of proteins that actually help
these processes which we won't talk
about in any detail the main thing that
you want to remember is that when the g
proteins are bound to gtp they're in a
non state GDP they're in an off state
and that's shown in this cartoon and
here I should be able to if all goes
according to plan show you the structure
of a GTP analogue bound to a g protein
so let's this little guys twirling
around he's settled down a little bit
the key thing you want to look at is
where it's magenta and cyan the
structure of the GDP and gtp bound g
protein are very very similar but big
changes happen in the yellow which is
the gdp-bound form and the red which is
the GT bound form let me go back again
so you can see that one more time so in
the GT gtp-bound form a portion of the
protein swings around and binds to that
third phosphate on the gtp and forms a
different shape to the structure and
that's a dynamic change that's
responsible for activation when it's
just D GDP that's shorter there's
nothing for that red arm to bind and so
it's much more of a floppy structure
what I want you to notice in that yellow
little yellow portion in the gdp-bound
form you actually don't really see where
the rest of the protein is this is
because this is a crystal structure and
in the crystal structure when things are
very mobile you can't even see electron
density it's as if the part of the
protein isn't
there because it is so dynamic it's only
in the gtp-bound form it forms this
tight compact structure that represents
an on a switch that has been turned on
does that make sense to everybody is
everyone good with that so just that
change that extra phosphate reaching
further to the protein and making an
interaction with the protein itself
makes the difference in the dynamics of
the g-protein and the activity here now
there are different types of G proteins
and you'll see both types reflected in
this lecture there are small G proteins
and they are monomeric and then there
are slightly more complicated G proteins
that are trimeric they have a hetero
trimeric structure so they have
quaternary structure where you have
three different proteins as part of the
complex so the other ones are trimeric
and it's the G protein actually
comprises three subunits where one of
them is the important one that binds GDP
or gtp but they're a little bit more
complicated and in the first example
when I talk about a particular response
to adrenaline we're going to see the
trimeric g-proteins and because they're
trimeric that means there's three
subunits and the convention is that they
get the Greek lettering system so they
are the alpha beta and gamma subunits
they've each got their name they're
three independent polypeptide chains and
is actually the alpha subunit the binds
GDP or gtp so that's one the formulation
of one of the types of switches that
we're gonna see when we start to look at
a pathway what you need to remember here
you need to focus on the fact
that in one state the protein is in an
off state it doesn't kick off a
signaling pathway but in the other state
the protein is a different shape because
of binding a link let's just make this a
little longer to that closed faith
that's negatively charged to the protein
so that's a non state and they're very
definitive types of structures now both
of these proteins are intracellular
which means they're part of the response
once a signal reaches a cell they're the
things that change and they're what the
the signal that gets transduced
to the g proteins now there's another
type of intracellular switch which is
used very very frequently in nature and
in fact it crosses permeates through all
kinds of cellular processes and these is
phosphorylation so here are the G
proteins which is one and the other one
is phosphorylation okay now remember we
talked about reactions of proteins that
alter their behavior their properties
their dynamics so protein
phosphorylation remember is a post
translational modification a PTM it's
something that happens to a protein
after it has been translated and folded
okay
and the PTMs that a phosphorylation are
involved OUP's amino acids that have OAH
groups so that's the structure of
tyrosine where the squiggles represent
the rest of the protein
and on phosphorylation we append a
phosphate group oops - - to the oxygen
on tyrosine on the sidechain so actually
it looks pretty different it behaves
pretty differently there are two other
residues in eukaryotic cells that are
commonly phosphorylated there the other
two that include Oh H groups so they are
serine and the third one to space but
you get the general message and
threonine so these are the three amino
acids that commonly get a phosphate
group attached and they change their
properties they are called kinase kinase
the root of the word is actually to
change so the enzymes that catalyze this
change are known as kinase a--'s and in
contrast to the G proteins that use gtp
the kinase is most commonly use ATP to
give up a phosphate to phosphorylate the
protein so there's another substrate in
this reaction is ATP now when we look at
this structure there's two or three
things I really want to call your
attention to once if we're dealing with
this kind of switch we can go back to
the off state by chopping up the gtp and
making it GDP again so that's how to
turn the light back off in the case of
the kinase 'iz we've got to do something
to go back from this state to the non
modified state to turn the light switch
off so for every transformation in the
cell that involves a kinase there is a
correspond
reading set of enzymes that reverse the
reaction called a phosphatase it takes
that group off again so let me write
that down here now phosphates used a lot
so this is a possible protein
phosphatase so kinase puts the phosphate
on the phosphoryl protein phosphatase
takes the phosphate off there are three
types of amino acids that get most
commonly modified in our cells tyrosine
serine and threonine and one of the ones
that forms an important part of an
extracellular signaling mechanism are
the tyrosine kinases and we'll delve
into them in a little bit in the next
second or but not the section I'm going
to cover now but later because tyrosine
various kinases come in a lot of
different flavors the common flavors of
whether you modify tyrosine or threonine
serine because these are more similar to
each other and this guy's different but
we'll get to that later so in the cell
we have about thirty twenty thousand
genes that encode proteins including
genes alright five hundred and fifteen
of those are kindnesses that's a pretty
big chunk of the genome you got to
accept so in excess of 500 our kinase is
specifically protein kinase is the ones
that modify so there's a big chunk of
the genome dedicated for this kind of
activity and these dynamic because
there's also about a hundred
phosphatases they're a little bit more
promiscuous you don't need so many of
them but a large sort of component of
the genome is responsible for
phosphorylating proteins and d
phosphorylating phospho proteins and
that part of the genome
it's own special name let's see I don't
know and it is called Buckeye gnome I
hope that's not too small in there so if
we're describing all the enzymes in the
genome that catalyze phosphorylation we
would call it the kinase a collective
set because it's the set of kinases and
you'll hear that term quite quite
commonly and the Tri no Ms really
important and represents major major
therapeutic targets because it's when
kinase is go wrong that we have
physiological defects so let's just go
back to this you can see we've got the
kinase and the phosphatase the donor for
phosphorylation is ATP and it is the
gamma phosphate that's transferred to
the protein to switch it from the off
state to the on state it is a post
translational modification meaning it
occurs on a protein after the protein
has been fully translated there are a
few Co translational PTMs
that seems like a bit of a an oxymoron
Co translational modifications but of
phosphorylation ISM one of them
glycosylation is and we won't go into
those in any detail even though it
breaks my heart not to go into those but
ok alright so now I want to first of all
introduce you to a paradigm for
signaling as opposed to really go into
what's happening and so one of the first
paradigms is a situation where you have
a cell in the plasma membrane of that
cell is a receptor and it gets hit with
a signal so a signaling paradigm is that
a molecule from outside the cell binds
to something that's transmembrane and
then you start getting signal
transduction through a pathway so any
extracellular signal could be could be
game in this process and then there's a
sequence events upon signal binding
there's a sequence of changes that ends
you up with a final output and generally
signaling pathways go through a number
of steps where is there is
the opportunity for the amplification of
a signal so I talked to you last about
time about some of the hallmarks of
signalling specificity defines how how
accurately that extracellular signal
binds to the receptor but amplification
really refers to how signals get bigger
and bigger through certain steps in a
signalling pathway in order to have a
big impact in the cell not just a single
event going through a single pathway one
molecule at a time and we'll see that in
the example that I show you okay then
oftentimes when we look at signaling
pathways we care a great deal about
what's the first response upon the
signal hitting the outside of the cell
so in many signaling pathways this could
be a protein the receptor could be a
protein that is bound to a g-protein and
that would be the first responder
through the pathway that really triggers
off the cellular events okay and now so
what I want to talk about now is the the
I always get this wrong I always thought
it was flight or fight or fight or
whatever right I always thought it was
flight or fright but it's not the the
response is actually the fight-or-flight
so let's set this up to understand why
this is such a great manifestation of a
cellular signaling response because it
includes a lot of the hallmarks that are
really characteristic of the cellular
response so this response involves a
cellular receptor that is called a
g-protein coupled
receptor we saw a little bit about them
last time they are always called GP CRS
for short and what that term means is
that it's a receptor that's linked in
some way to a g-protein so it could be
coupled to a monomeric or a trimeric
g-protein so don't confuse the two one
is the receptor it's transmembrane it's
responsible for transducing receiving
signals and transducing them the first
responder is the g-protein that changes
from a gdp-bound state to a gtp bound
state and in the one that we're going to
talk about we're going to deal with a
trimeric g-protein in the fight or
flight response and what you see here is
a cartoon of the players that are
involved so remember the G proteins we
talked about them briefly last time they
have seven transmembrane helix C's they
span the membrane they have the
n-terminal outside whoops one two three
four five six seven and terminus out C
terminus in and each of these is a
transmembrane helix and this would be
outside the cell this would be in the
cytoplasm okay and you can actually
often look at a transmembrane protein
and know its behavior because the width
of these transmembrane helix e's often
comes in at approximately forty angstrom
which is the span of a membrane you can
sort of say that looks like a
transmembrane helix it's exactly that
dimension to cross a membrane and the
trans the
GPCRs in this case would bind to a
ligand outside the cell and have a
response inside the cell so those seven
transmembrane helix E's are responding
to ligand binding so let's take a look
at this picture because it's almost
impossible for me to get it onto the
screen so that the its binds to a
trimeric g-protein remember I talked to
you about the two different types the
trimeric has an alpha beta and gamma
subunit quaternary structure and they're
shown here in different colors the green
is the alpha subunit the magenta is the
or the red is the gamma subunit and the
yellow is the beta subunit so what
happens when the ligand binds to the
g-protein there is a reorganization of
that G Pro excuse me when it binds to
the G protein-coupled receptor there is
a reorganization of those seven
transmembrane helix E's last time I
identified them to you when you look at
a couple of these they're actually
fairly large loops that grab onto your
ligand and that will translate
conformational information through the
membrane to the other side where the G
proteins are sitting and in this
response what happens is upon binding
the ligand the alpha subunit leaves the
team and goes from there GDP GDP bound
States to the GT bound State so it
literally changes its state and changes
its mode of Association within the cell
upon that action so you can see how
nicely we have transduced the ligand
binding out here to a pretty discrete
cellular event turning on the switch of
the g-protein alpha subunit is everyone
following me there I know it so it looks
complicated to start with B or C it in
in action okay so here are the cellular
components of the of the response so
basically this is the kind of response
where if you get scared or you feel
you're in harm's way you will trigger
this response
in order to generate a lot of a lot of
ATP in order that you can respond run
away high to do something very active in
order to rapidly respond to a threat of
some kind and this response is triggered
by a small molecule in this case it's
epinephrine or adrenaline different
names on different sides of the Atlantic
but you all know what adrenaline is and
here's the structure of epinephrine or
adrenaline and it is the signal for the
flight off right the flight or fight
response because it's the small molecule
that binds to the extracellular surface
of the receptor changes its shape so
that things can happen intracellularly
and it's just one small molecule
normally that would be charged it
doesn't diffuse across the membrane so
it's stuck being on the outside of the
membrane okay so this is the signal that
triggers the response so if you have to
respond to a threat of some kind
you can't stop sort of go to the fridge
get a big snack eat it
you know digest all your food and hope
you're going to get energy quickly what
you've got to do is have a response
where you can generate energy from your
glycogen stores that are in the liver so
there is a signal comes from the adrenal
region which is the release of
adrenaline that goes to the cell surface
receptors to trigger the response and
what kind of signal would this be would
it be paracrine autocrine EXO crying
what kind of signal would that be oh
sorry endocrine para crying
Chuckster crime do you remember last
time yeah
endocrine so it's a response that comes
from the kidneys and goes to the liver
so it's going it's traveling autocrine
is self paracrine is near juxtacrine is
cell contact but any of these hormonal
responses are pretty commonly endocrine
responses so what happens once the
signal binds so the specificity in this
situation is that the g-protein coupled
with
now shown in pink in very stylized form
but you can count those seven
transmembrane domains will bind
exclusively to this GPCR with high
specificity another signal another small
molecule that looks like it won't bind
because we have to have specificity for
the signal upon that binding event it
will trigger a change within the cell
and that change within the cell is that
the alpha subunit here you see alpha
subunit beta gamma they're all shown in
green the alpha subunit of the g-protein
remember I told you it was a trimeric
g-protein where the alpha subunit is the
key player the alpha subunit leaves the
team and it exchanges its G GDP that's
its resting state nothing's happening
for gtp which turns it on so that's the
first response the g-protein is
responding to the signal from the
outside of the cell through the auspices
of the g-protein coupled receptor to
give a change within the cell that's a
discrete change okay
following me so far so now what we need
to do is trigger the remaining
biochemical events that are going to get
us out of this sticky situation where we
need to produce a lot of ATP so it turns
out that the gtp-bound form of the alpha
subunit can then bind to another enzyme
and that enzyme is adenylate cyclase so
we've found we've changed the gdp to GTP
there's a response and we activate the
enzyme known as AC which you look up
here it's called adenylate cyclase so
this is a messenger within the cell
that's now being generated as a response
to the signal coming from outside
through the GPCR to the alpha subunit of
the g protein which then in its
gtp-bound state binds adenylate cyclase
okay is everyone with me and once that
is bound adenylate cyclase can do its
biochemistry and the biochemistry that
adenylate cyclase
as shown down here here's a teepee
adenylate cyclase cyclize --is ATP you
lose two of the phosphates and you get
this molecule known as cyclic a MP which
is a messenger molecule that will
propagate information through the cell
all right once that happens so now the
adenylate cyclase is activated because
it's bound to the gtp-bound form of the
alpha subunit that means we can make a
bunch of cyclic a MP and cyclic a MP is
what's known as a second messenger and
that often means it's a common messenger
in a lot of pathways it shows up quite
frequently within the wiring of a
pathway and it acts locally to where the
pathway is being is being processed
so once cyclic a MP is formed from
adenylate site by adenylate cyclase that
then activates an enzyme it activates
protein protein kinase a so PKA is a
kinase it's actually a serine threonine
kinase and that then results in certain
proteins within the cell becoming
phosphorylated to continue propagating
our effect so we have specificity by the
adrenaline binding we have amplification
somewhere in this pathway so I told you
that many pathways go through steps
where you start amplifying the signal
where do you think is the first stage in
this set of transformations that I
describe to you where you start
amplifying the information think about
what each of the events comprises what
what is it what's you know is this one
binding to one
one event or is it one binding to one
and we get multiple events where is the
first step of amplification that's
essential because it wouldn't do us any
good if we make one molecule of ATP at
the end of the day we've got to make
dozens and dozens of molecules of ATP
what what's the first event that could
be an amplification over there yeah when
it's made yes
so this let's go through them one by
pnes two one great
once one binds to one one of these is
released it gets converted to one of
these once one of these is made
adenylate cyclase is an enzyme so it can
make a bunch of cyclic ANP which can
then activate a bunch of protein kinase
a which can then phosphorylate a bunch
of cellular proteins so we got an
expansion of our response all right so
everyone does that make sense to
everyone
so amplification is really important
feedback is also important if you ended
up needing an EpiPen because you have an
allergic response you might remember
that you've got the jitters forever
because there's too much firing an
action going on but in though that the
fight-or-flight response there's
feedback at a certain stage that slows
down this entire process and that
feedback actually comes from an enzyme
that chomps up the cyclic ANP to make it
inactive as a second messenger so
there's feedback in this process okay
now what happens within the cell to get
us that biological response this is a
sort of a shortened version of what's
happening so epinephrine binds here we
are with the alpha subunit with cyclic
A&P you know through each one of these
you might make twenty molecules of
cyclic ANP that would in activate many
many PKS
and then you go through a series of
biochemical steps where different
enzymes are activated with the overall
goal of in the liver chewing up glycogen
okay so glycogen is a pretty
impenetrable polymer of carbohydrates
and you need several enzymes to start to
break glycogen down
to make glucose phosphate and so these
enzymes here of Prospero lays B kinase a
glycation phosphorylase all end up
converting glycogen into glucose
1-phosphate so you access your liver
stores of stored carbohydrate which is
in a polymeric form to get a lot of
glucose phosphate which is then
hydrolyzed to glucose which then hits
the blood system and then you can
deliver glucose to all the cells to go
glycolysis and make ATP and every
glucose molecule as you know can really
turn out ATP so what we see in this
process is going through the entire
dynamics of the system where we've seen
specificity amplification and feedback
later on I'll describe integration to
you ok
everyone following the series of steps
that go from a Maalik molecular
messenger to biochemical steps to
physiological biological response now I
want to just emphasize one quick thing
here I've got a couple of slides I
popped in of drug targets about 45% of
receptors in cells 25% of the entire
drug targets are GPCRs they respond to
all kinds of signals amines amino acids
lipids little peptides proteins
nucleosides all commonly going through
the g-protein coupled receptor to give
you a similar phenomenon to what I've
described to you and what I thought was
think is particularly interesting this
is not I'm gonna post all of these are
slides what I want yous to see this was
quite a while back but it just shows you
so many of trademark drugs that targets
different gpcrs they're shown here and
what diseases they're used for to treat
and what's the generic name of those
drugs so you can see here many many
diseases have at the heart and soul of
their the problem different receptors
and these are all g-protein coupled
receptors that are treated with small
molecules the bind to the
and often glue it in an inactive state
so it can't then bind to an activating
signal and have all the rest of the
events occur there are very few
structures of the g-protein coupled
receptors but there are some of them so
many of the target g-protein coupled
receptors can be modeled computationally
and then you can do a lot of work where
you actually model the receptor in a
membrane environment and start searching
for drugs through computational
approaches and I thought a lot of you
might be interested in this because this
is a really strong axis where
bioinformatics confirmation and advanced
physics in molecular dynamics can be
brought to bear on drug discovery when
you don't have perfect molecular models
of your targets okay so now we're gonna
move to a different kind of signal we're
gonna talk about the receptor tyrosine
kinase ISM alright so in the receptor
tyrosine kinase responses we can often
see very similar paradigms to what I've
just shown you but there is an important
distinction receptor tyrosine kinase is
we often call these are T Ches so that's
their shorthand so over here I described
to you two different kinase 'iz that we
have kinase a--'s that modify threonine
serine and tyrosine the receptor
tyrosine kinase is a subset of tyrosine
kinase --is that form part of a receptor
so if you were to think about various
kinase 'iz you would have the serine
threonine and you would have the
tyrosine ones but these would be
differentiated into the ones that are
parked part of a membrane protein the
rtks and then the ones that are soluble
in the cytoplasm
and the serine threonine ones are most
commonly soluble in the cytoplasm I'm
going to focus on the receptor tyrosine
kinases because they do slightly
different activities when they signal
relative to the GPCRs so let's once
again this situation another paradigm
where you see a series of events but
with a number of the receptor tyrosine
kinase pathways the ultimate action ends
up being in the nucleus where as a
result of an extracellular signal you
get a series of events that ends up with
a protein being sent into the nucleus
and that protein may be a transcription
factor the binds to a promoter region
and as a result of that you'll get gene
transcription occur
you'll transcribe a gene make a
messenger RNA that will leave the
nucleus and cause action within the cell
so this is a little bit different than
the other response that was mainly
cytoplasmic okay so let's take a look at
the receptor tyrosine kinases receptor
tyrosine kinases are proteins that span
the membrane but rather differently from
the gpcrs and they have a domain that's
extracellular just a single
transmembrane domain this is out this is
in and then they have an intracellular
domain this would be where the ligand
binds this would be how there's some
kind of signal transducing and this
would be a kinase domain okay so how do
we get the information in when we saw
the gpcrs we saw the ability of those
7tms to kind of reorganize and send
information in the cell with the
receptor tyrosine kinase --is it's kind
of different there are regions of the
membrane where there are a lot of these
proteins they commonly bind small
peptides and protein molecules and when
they're in their activated form once the
small protein binds the receptor
tyrosine try
forms a dimeric structure that is two of
these get together only upon
ligand-binding they move together once
there is a ligand bound and then what
happens is that the tyrosine kinase
domains phosphorylate each other and
that's activation in the case of
receptor tyrosine kinases so when the
small protein ligand is not around this
is a singleton it doesn't work on itself
once this ligand binds interactions
change you get a dimeric structure where
one kinase can cost correlate what's
called in trans the other kinase domain
so it's different from the GPCRs it's a
different kind of feel to it but it's
still a dynamic transient signal let's
take a look at this within a cell and
see what kinds of responses and this is
in our response to EGF which is
epidermal growth factor
it's a cytokine that promotes cell
division so a lot happens with respect
to the action of a cell not to produce
ATP but now to respond by producing all
the elements that enable cells to grow
and proliferate so the epidermal growth
factor binds you get dimerization upon
that dimerization the kinase domain in
one structure in the blue one
phosphorylates the other and vice versa
they phosphorylate each other
intermolecular ly once that has happened
through the auspices of another protein
i won't bother you with the name of this
phosphorylated intracellular RT k binds
to a small g-protein in this case it's a
monomeric g-protein not one of the
trimeric ones a small one known as
wrasse once that binding event occurs
guess what wrasse gets activated it's
now binding GTP instead of gdp and then
it starts going through a sequence of
events where there's a ton
of cellular phosphorylate controlled
cellular phosphorylation events the
result in moving a protein into the
nucleus that helps form a transcription
complex the results in cellular
proliferation similar but different
series of events they're still
amplification they're still dynamics and
in this case it's a lot of
phosphorylation events and what I want
to sort of define for you is that many
of these pathways are in trouble in
disease state speed inflammation neuro
degeneration or cancer there are a
Bearnaise aberrant behavior of proteins
within these pathways that cause them to
go wrong cause cells to proliferate out
of control or undergo bad responses and
that is why these proteins end up being
therapeutic targets like the g-protein
coupled receptors okay so we've seen the
characteristics of signaling we've seen
a signal we've seen amplification we've
seen responses but I just want to
quickly show you is an idea about
integration so here's an idea with two
signaling pathways that sort of end up
with the same signal outside where you
integrate actions through two different
signaling pathways to achieve a bigger
different kind of response so that's
that last hallmark of signaling pathways
it's not that every pathway is clean and
straight
it has crosstalk with other pathways and
you get amplified or different responses
tremendously complicated I want to give
you one more term and then I'll show one
table when these pathways go wrong it's
often because switches get stuck on so
for example a gtp a g-protein gets stuck
in its gtp bound state or doesn't even
need gtp to be activated or a tyrosine
kinase is stuck activated and that's
what's called constitutively active
I mean base basically meaning it's
permanently on so many of the diseases
that are caused by mutations in your
genome not genetic diseases but
mutations in your genes in some
particular cells end up with
constitutive activation where you don't
need a signal to have a response and so
for example cells may proliferate out of
control so that is an important term to
know and understand because constitutive
activation basically means that a
receptor may be active in the absence of
a ligand and I believe this is my last
slide I just wanted to leave you with
this when one thinks of GPC ours their
tremendous therapeutic targets the world
of kinase is is no less important these
scale is in billions of dollars spent on
developing molecules that may be
curative of diseases that involve
dysregulated signaling and what you see
on this I want to point out two things
I'm going to go in of course this thing
stopped working at the last minute but
what I want to point out is this
particular bar this represents the
billions of dollars spent on protein
kinase inhibitors over-fire a five-year
period and it's just escalating and
escalating
similarly monoclonal antibodies are very
important but the small molecule drugs
hold a real dominance what do these
drugs do they enable you to have small
molecules that can go into dysregulated
signaling pathways and stop the activity
somewhere in the pathway to avoid
signals going constantly to the nucleus
and turning things on all the time so
that both of these types of functions in
cellular signaling once you want to
understand both from a biological
perspective but from a medical
perspective okay
you